fun times Mike what can you tell us
about the situation with Jerry Jones and
the Commissioner well you know it was
funny I heard the other night that Jerry
Jones was no longer part of the
compensation committee he had kind of
wedged his way onto it and he'd been
pushing the agenda fighting back against
the terms of the contract I didn't know
why he was that but then as of yesterday
when the New York Times reported it well
now I know why they voted him off the
committee he's threatened litigation no
one knows it be serious about it
Friday is the day to watch to see if
something gets filed nobody knows what
legal theories he may have you can't
just sue someone because you don't like
what they did you have to have some
basis for breach of contract some sort
of right that is recognized by law that
in some way has been violated and no one
knows what his claims would be but Jerry
is so determined to try to block this
extension process he's tried it
internally with owners he's tried it
externally with Pappajohn and now he's
potentially going to try through the
court system and it all traces to the
belief and this was reported yesterday
by Clarence Hill the Fort Worth
star-telegram
the Commissioner lied to Jerry about
Ezekiel Elliott not being suspended at
Jones even though he's not linking the
two I think Jones is motivated by that
upset that he has over being told
something other than the truth at least
that's what he believes you know he may
have misheard him it may be a
misunderstanding through those but he
believes he was lied to and that's
apparently what's motivating yeah I was
told last night that the Clarence Hill
report was true it was accurate that the
Commissioner said something one thing
and then all of a sudden you know went
back on that and then Ezekiel he gets
suspended and that's why Jerry's upset
and it feels like Jerry wants to say to
the commissioner hey I'm your boss
you're the commissioner I'm your boss
and I'm gonna delay this I'm gonna let
you know that I can make your life
miserable I still think he gets the
contract extension now you did bring up
Papa John's what what happened in that
well I never been admitted but I think
the circumstances make it clear that
when John Schnatter the CEO of Papa
John's on a quarterly earnings call read
from prepared remarks it just blasted
the NFL's leadership for the lingering
anthem controversy and length ongoing
revenue declines for Papa John's
- the leads declining ratings that that
was instigated by Jerry Jones who owns
all are part of 120 Papa John's stores
and when Jones was asked about it he
didn't do anything to distance himself
from the remarks he essentially clapped
Schnatter on the back and said he's a
great American and he understands the
consumer and you know essentially
everything he said is true so that I
feel like that was another attempt but
he's denying everything he can and being
the bag with every club in there to try
to stop this extension and we've got you
know the effort to build enough support
within the ownership ranks that's not
working
sponsorship pressure that really didn't
last more than a day or two and now this
effort to to file suit and you know he's
he's not going to give up right or wrong
successful unsuccessful you don't get
the impression he's gonna give up
Ezekiel Elliott finds out when if he's
going to be able to play the rest of the
season is it next week today two o'clock
Eastern and I suspect that they'll be a
ruling by tomorrow morning at the latest
maybe by the end of the day they
couldn't rule from the bench it's gonna
be three judges they they weren't
supposed to do a hearing
Elliot's people were shocked that a
hearing was scheduled these motions
typically get handled this is a
full-blown appeal it's an intermediate
step they typically get handled without
a hearing and they were happy hear that
there was a hearing they view that as
good news and they think it means that
these judges are taking it very
seriously it's a very extraordinary
remedy to put an injunction in place on
a temporary basis at the appeals court
level that's what they're trying to do
and and then if you went that and he
could find out as soon as today
he plays home a full appeal of the
decision from last week is resolved
which you know who knows one that's my
comment and there's still is a chance
that Elliot finds out he's suspended
middle of December and the six games
bleed into the post seed and if the
Cowboys make it yeah that's a mess man
it's a mess he's Mike Florio pro
football talk.com and pro football talk
on NBC Sports Network I also saw a teddy
bridgewater wait is teddy bridgewater
gonna be the starter in Minnesota at
some point this season I think the key
is knowing when to flip the switch you
have to have a feel for the right time
teddy bridgewater case Kane has played
better than expected in the time that
he's played this year in place of Sam
rabbit but they haven't faced a really
tough schedule and Keenan hadn't been
doing franchise quarterback beating guys
like Brett Hundley DeSean Kaiser Joe
Flacco who isn't the guy that used to be
mean it has not been a murderer's row
that they face no these guys nothing out
like perfect others maybe I can lose a
lumen they've got Matthew Stafford down
the line I bet you're at Gotham Iran's
coming to town and I think the key is
going to be for the coaching staff to
know when to go from King to Bridgewater
and here's a reality bridge whiners
never played for pattern with the offset
support he plays for north turner he was
ready to go last year as of late August
with north turner tore the ACL had other
damage and now that he's back it's a
different offense and I think that's a
factory though the knees he ordered he's
ready to go when do you know the offense
and wonder the white 16 has dipped
enough to open the door for Bridgewater
and if Keenan keeps playing well who
knows how long Bridgewater sits on the
bench thank you Mike great to talk to
you again I'll see you on Sunday that's
Mike Florio pro football time for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]